good morning hick it's Tuesday so a
couple weeks ago some folks presented a
tuberculosis research study at a
conference that got a standing ovation
and I think it has implications not only
for TB treatment but also for how we can
speed up Innovation around treating
other diseases from malaria to cancer
okay so to cure tuberculosis you need to
take a cocktail of antibiotics because
the bacterium that causes it micob
bacterium tuberculosis is notoriously
hard to kill and for people with
multi-drug resistant tuberculosis TB
that doesn't respond to the first line
of antibiotics if they're lucky enough
to get treated at all they have to take
a regimen that lasts between 18 and 24
months and that cocktail of drugs
includes injectable medications that are
so toxic and painful that one TV
Survivor describe them to me as having
an injection of lava into your body
patients could expect to take around
13,000 pills in addition to the
injections all of this the sheer number
of pills the serious side effects the
18mon long treatment means that many
people are unable to finish their
treatment and die as a result and when
you add that to the fact that most
people with mdrtb are never even able to
access accurate Diagnostics or effective
treatments you get the catastrophe that
we have now where only around 10% of
people with multi-drug resistant
tuberculosis are cured now in the last
few years a much better regimen has
emerged that works for many people it
requires only five pills per day it's
becoming a more affordable regimen but
it's still relatively expensive and it
also involves a drug that is not widely
available in many poor countries plus
you can't take it if you're a kid or
pregnant enter the standing ovation NTB
trials so for the last several years
Partners in Health Doctors Without
Borders unit Aid and other organizations
have been working together on a
randomized control trial to test if it's
possible to cure mdrtb with shorter
regimens using existing drugs so in
seven countries around the world they
they gave some people the existing
18-month standard of care and other
people one of five new regimens lasting
just nine months and what they found is
that three of those regimens achieved
similar or slightly better cure rates
after 9 months than the standard regimen
does after 18 months and one achieved
significantly better cure rates after 9
months than the 18-month regimen with
around 90% of people being cured of
mdrtb the two best regimens were also
pretty safe and as a little bonus the
least expensive so no toxic injectables
9 months instead of 18 months better
cure rates for less money currently the
18-month regimen costs about $5,000 per
person the two best 9month NTB regimens
cost about $300 per person and some of
that is because Johnson and Johnson is
not pursuing secondary patents on
baceline which is in part thanks to you
nerd fter so we have better shorter
safer cheaper cures for multi-drug
resistant tuberculosis as a result of
this trial now hopefully the who will
recommend these new shorter regimens
soon meaning more people surviving mdrtb
and less overall mdrtb in the world but
also the who should know that if they
don't recommend these new regimens
quickly uh we and other groups of TV
activists and survivors will be knocking
on their door quite incess recently
what's most interesting to me about the
NTB trial is that they weren't trying to
prove that some new patentable compound
would change everything and make
billions of dollars they were using
existing drugs albeit some that were
quite new in Innovative combinations and
that's the kind of trial that drug
companies just don't have much incentive
to create we see this in cancer
treatment too there is always incentive
to create trials around new compounds
that are patentable but when it comes to
using existing compounds in different
combinations or at different dosages in
order to increase cure rates that's much
harder to get money for 1.6 million
people are going to die of TB this year
and yes we need to invest in new drugs
and new drug classes and new treatments
but also 1.6 million people are going to
die this year and they can't wait for
those new compounds they need drugs that
are here now and the NTB trial says to
them there is hope for you we need to do
a better job of funding that kind of
trial now in the world of cancer public
money and private donations have funded
many of those experiments but we need
more and with neglected diseases like TB
we need massive investment the NTB
trials could have started a decade ago
and we'd already be at a point where for
years we'd known about these new 9month
regimens that are just as or more
effective we could have saved so much
needless suffering and death by finding
these better safer faster cures that oh
by the way are also much less expensive
the NTB trials are not going to make any
one individual a billion dollars but
they are going to make all of humanity
less poor and less sick Hank I'll see
you on Friday